while you were speaking i just did the
search this is
national membership by year from 22
to 1950 right and you see it it
increases a little bit right after war
obviously the date you gave
uh bolshevik was 1917.
us was 1919 and china was 1921 it's
almost every two years one of them came
out with their chinese with their
communist party so the the membership's
going up
while the economy is bad but the moment
the economy improves
membership goes down the moment 1929
crash happens
look how the membership goes up because
it's all you know
they need they need a massive crisis for
them to push their agenda
the moment economy recovers their
memberships goes down
it's such a tough time for these guys
today to make their argument
because the rich are getting richer and
the poor are getting richer so
it's you know this saying where the rich
are getting richer and the poor are
getting poorer
the only part that that makes sense is
the following i was a kid that grew up
in a family where my dad was a 99 cents
for cashier in englewood
my dad never sat me down and explained
to me what a 401k is my parents have
never owned a 401k my parents have never
owned a stock
a mutual fund an annuity an insurance
policy a life insurance policy
never owned the house i've never lived
in a house i've always lived in an
apartment complex nobody told me
here's what rule of 72 is here's what
byte you know here's what uh
buy and hold this here's what the dollar
cost averaging is here's what a roth ira
is i
i don't know any of that kind of stuff
my dad was a cashier at 99 cent store
he was making 1500 bucks a month is what
he was making so
that was never taught to me about how
money worked
and so gradually the rich got richer and
the poor is getting richer we're making
more money yeah every in every possible
way life is getting better
better so their argument isn't working
so in order for them to effectively
impose their argument
they have to go back to what you were
talking about antonio
gramsci which you know he talks about
cultural hegemony which i'm sure you're
familiar with culture hegemony
if by the way i don't want to read the
definition would you mind taking a quick
second here and telling everybody what
culture hegemony is
i'm sure you've spoken about this in
your book i do write about it in the
book
uh he's written there's a there's a
short
if i'm not mistaken there's a short
paper even that you can go read about
this
um understanding cultural hegemony but
we did touch upon it earlier it's
this idea as you pointed out look at the
graph that you
that you put up on the screen there
remember remember there was
frankfurt school marxists that come over
into the united states
uh on the tail end of that crash in at
the beginning of the 1930s and you see
the communist party usa numbers boom
during that period
and it's the same time period
that gramsci and others are pushing this
idea
that you have to divorce people in
western society
from their traditional values their
traditional culture their traditional
norms
and you need to replace it with a
different set of values a different set
of norms in a different culture
and if you're able to do that
successfully now as you pointed out the
economic stratification argument the
idea that the working
class is going to continue getting
poorer and need to rise up in revolution
against their
their captors the capitalist ruling
class
that was not a successful narrative
to use to spur violent revolution in a
place like the united states
but that's when that same time period
where the numbers are booming there
and when we're talking about cultural
hegemony antonio gramsci and others that
are grabbing a hold of that idea that we
should divorce
people from their traditional values and
replace it with a separate
ideology during that same period is when
you see the development of both critical
theory and it morph
into critical legal theory let me read
you something from my book just briefly
here please
that i've got because it gets right at
it's going to take me 10 seconds to find
it so
here it is it actually took me three
seconds to find it you're good
you're a fighter i don't even have a
mark page 102 of my book
so today critical legal scholars at
harvard university help us make the link
between
critical legal theory and the now
popular and pervasive
critical race theory the harvard berkman
klein center has a page
on on their website about critical legal
theory today
specifying what it is and it and it's
related to what we're talking about
critical legal theory scholars focused
from the start this is a direct quote
from their website
on the ways that law contributed to
illegitimate social hierarchies
okay pay very close attention to the
language producing domination of women
by men
non-whites by whites and the poor
by the wealthy this is a pr classic
oppressor versus oppressed narrative
that is showing up in our high our educa
our institutions of higher learning
they claim this is again still a direct
quote from the harvard uh
berkman klein center's website they
claim that apparently neutral language
and institutions
apparently neutral language and
institutions
operated through law mask relationships
of power
the emphasis on individualism within the
law similarly
hides patterns of power relationships
while making it more difficult to summon
up
a sense of community and human
interconnection now
let me connect that quote from harvard's
website
uh now this is critical legal theory
this is a half century old
to the current uh far more politicized
critical race theory ibram kendy's book
how to be an anti-racist has come up
a number of times in the media in the
last few months and specifically in the
last week i've talked about it
in the introduction to his book and this
is this is going to be
some quotes directly from his book candy
mentions that color blindness
martin luther king jr's dream and ideal
for
western society and for american society
specifically color blindness
is racist passivity these are not my
words these are candies words
color blindness is a mask to hide
racism and the constitution of the
united states
is a colorblind racist constitution for
a white supremacist
america those are ideological talking
points
that are rooted in marxism with the
intent on dividing the american people
okay so you can see how
cultural the idea of cultural hegemony
planted
planting the seeds of division over time
in our
institutions of higher learning manifest
today tactically and methodologically
in the writings of critical race
scholars and then he goes on to say if
you consider yourself
not racist i don't care what your race
is i don't care what your political
party is
that is that is the language of
neutrality
not racist you are either racist and
admit it
or you're racist and you deny it
confirming your racism
if you claim to be not racist you are
quote like the trumps
and other white supremacists of the
world so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye